So as of this recording, we don't yet know
the winner of the 20 20 presidential election,
but unfortunately, we can now say with complete
certainty that this is a country that is screwed,
whether Trump wins or loses for a long period
of time.
Now, I know some of you won't like this commentary.
The votes have been cast.
There's no more votes to cast.
They need to be counted.
Me saying this now won't change anything.
Of course, if Joe Biden becomes president,
the country is able to possibly start reorienting
in the right direction.
Joe Biden has paths to victory and Donald
Trump has paths to victory.
It would be huge for Joe Biden to become president.
We can start to repair global relationships.
We can start to be a little bit less of a
global laughing stock.
But almost 67 million people have already
voted for Donald Trump.
About five million more people have voted
for Donald Trump this year than in 2016.
Win or lose, that is a recipe for a destroyed
country.
We have to realize that when we see coronavirus
economy, race protests, these are the top
issues and Trump's not polling well in them.
That doesn't mean that your average Trump
actually connects their vote to what is happening
in their state and says, oh, I will then not
vote for Trump because I think he's not doing
well on these issues.
Pandemic running rampant in my state because
our governor is buddy buddy with Trump and
they're ignoring guidelines and opening everything
and having huge events.
So the virus spreads and hurts the economy.
Yeah, I do disapprove of that.
But vote for Joe Biden, but no way I'm voting
for Donald Trump again.
Win or lose, we have not 60 million, but 67
million trumpet's who live in this country
who will continue to live here no matter who
wins the presidential election.
My dad has written recently in Spanish about
how to understand Trump because truly, how
do you understand millions more votes for
Trump in the midst of one of the worst performances
in the world on the pandemic?
It doesn't make sense if you are rational
and thinking empirically.
The answer, as my dad has written, is magical
or mythical thinking among his supporters.
Trump supporters see themselves at being as
being at war against the left, against Democrats,
against the media, against scientists, against
atheists, against communists and Marxists
and all of that stuff.
They see themselves as at war.
They also idealize violence and these ideas
of courage and risk taking things by force,
imposing their opinions because they are better
and because America is first, as they say.
So when you understand the mindset, when you're
at war, a normal way of interacting with the
world and others evaporates.
And you justify, as we've seen, actual militaries
justify all over the world, you justify absurd
and immoral behavior.
In that situation.
Lying is completely valid if you're at war.
I mean, come on, guys, it's a war.
Lies lies are no big deal.
We're at war here.
And so when they say things like the virus
isn't that serious, we wonder, are they in
denial?
Do they not understand?
No, no.
They are accepting that.
Listen, old folks, immigrants stuck at the
border with the virus, weak people with comorbidities,
they're going to have to die.
We are essentially culling the weak and some
of us will die as well.
They know some of their people are also going
to die, but it's worth it to win the war,
which in their mind is we must support Trump
and we must defend Trump at all costs, no
matter what those costs are.
And my dad wrote, it's just like the war approach
of we're going to take some casualties, but
it's worth it because we're going to win the
war.
It's not just wishful thinking, because wishful
thinking is more individualistic.
This is really a mythical thinking.
It's a cultish thinking, which is really more
of a group psychology element.
It's more of a social force.
And each Trump cultist sees themselves as
individual agents recruited by the cause to
push their values and talking points with
any weapon they can.
And those weapons include straight up lies
spreading fake news, going out without a mask,
casting a vote for Trump even if he screwed
up the pandemic.
They're in love with their traditional sort
of fascistic of.
Oratory and values, these are authoritarians,
they are sort of fighting their Stalingrad
against the abnormal as they see it the week
as they see it, and they believe, many of
them, that God is on their side.
Everything that seems despicable to other
people who are involved in what should be
a democratic process.
It's different when they are already at war.
They are operating under the logic of war.
We are operating under the logic of anti authoritarianism
and democracy.
So whether Biden wins or not, this problem
I've outlined doesn't go away.
And what we need to understand is that confronting
what I just described with empiricism, argumentation,
rationality, facts, it doesn't account for
the reality that they are in a cultish, mythical,
magical thinking space.
They're thinking of the myth of this is a
war.
It will never reach them to say, but look
at these facts.
You understand the facts.
So how do we interrupt it?
I don't have any idea.
Let's first figure out who won the presidency.
This is not an election that should be this
close.
But again, because of these people, this election
should be ninety nine to one in favor of Biden,
based on Trump's actions, based on Trump's
authoritarianism.
But that's not how his supporters even think
about the world.
The fact that people vote for Trump is in
and of itself stunning in a normal country,
even with a sort of white nationalist identity,
Aryan Nation hyper nationalistic streak, someone
like Trump wouldn't get more than, you know,
being generous, 30 percent of the vote.
And it would probably be more in the teens
here.
Donald Trump got nearly 70 million votes,
nearly 70 million votes.
So I'm getting ahead of myself because I've
said after the election we will address the
problem of Trump ism.
First, let's figure out who the next president
is going to be The David Pakman Show at David
Pakman Dotcom.